President Joe Biden said that the  pandemic is over wait real question is  it over that's what I want is it over  you know it can honestly it don't even  matter because I'm pretty sure covet is  going to haunt us forever it's like our  old jokes on Twitter or or Madonna on  Tick Tock oh goodness  take a look at this [ __ ] but that's her  you know watch this that's Madonna there  Madonna back up back the [ __ ] up Madonna  good no what you doing what is she doing  oh all right thank you okay thank you  very much I don't understand what that  was well nobody does to be honest with  you if I can get that part of my life  back I'd do anything to happen I mean  what just happened man yeah but I mean  she looks great yep come on now yeah  right yeah yes we we need right love  lover nobody has explained to her the  algorithm of how Tick Tock works yeah  she thinks this yeah yeah based on  closeness I don't know what that was yes  it's not